expand next on public lives Edmund
Morgan discusses his new biography of
Benjamin Franklin this program from the
friends select school in Philadelphia is
about an hour
you have to have a lot of nerve to come
to Philadelphia and presume to tell us
about Benjamin Franklin I mean we have
Franklin Court Franklin Square a
Benjamin Franklin bridge a Franklin
Institute Franklin Art ranges from the
sublime who died at the Museum to the
massive Franklin at the Institute to a
lump of Franklin and pennies in Old City
there's the Academy he found it now the
University of Pennsylvania a library
fire departments the lightning-rod the
Declaration Constitution were all over
the stuff or maybe it takes a wiser man
to come to Philadelphia and say let's
look again at this man using only
Franklin's writings professor Morgan has
delved into the inner life of the man
giving us an involving portrait a
sterling professor of history at Yale
and author of numerous books and
articles on the colonial period
including one of my favorite early
history books the Puritan dilemma and
the important American slavery American
freedom the ordeal of colonial Virginia
professor Morgan he's uniquely qualified
to set the life of Franklin and really
he's in the right age group no life
quite encompasses the sweep of colonial
experiences Franklin's he participates
in early founding disputes franchises
his printing business raises a militia
Franklin's dealing with the Quakers is
fascinating but halfway through the book
Franklin is already 60 years old or put
another way by professor Morgan's
account half of Franklin's life occurred
after he turned 60 professor Morgan
takes time to explain Franklin's dispute
with Penn's son which foreshadows later
disputes with Parliament and is possibly
a source of Franklin's
early recognition than in England that
refused to recognize ministers refused
local militia and refused colonial
representation in Parliament really had
no right to govern colonies further we
become aware of Franklin's leadership
style which seems to be something akin
to becoming indispensable
or we notice what an industry a famous
person is parties correspondence to
well-wishers advice the expanded edition
I could go on professor Morgan's
biography will send you to Franklin's
papers and the later documents are gold
there you'll find his final address to
the Constitutional Convention where read
a statements as president of
Pennsylvania society for promoting the
abolition of slavery though the
automatic teller machine forces us to
look at our ante Jackson's the world
currency is Franklin one wishes Franklin
the one wishes the Franklin professor
Morgan has redefined for us would gain
currency Franklin was a negotiator a
subtle secular spirit ready to doubt but
full of curiosity and Industry deeply
caring of his fellow humans and unafraid
to act with great boldness for their
betterment it is really a pleasure to
present to you tonight Edmund as Morgan
thank you
it is pretty bold for someone from
Connecticut to come to Philadelphia and
talk about Benjamin Franklin but
somebody's somebody's got to talk about
to talk to you about him who isn't one
of you know so I'll give it a try and
what I ask first why do people read
biographies and why do historians write
them because the two questions are
slightly different answers I spent the
better part of 10 years on a life of
azeris tiles the 18th century New
England Minister who incidentally served
for time as president of Yale I thought
he was worth the trouble as a historian
because file was interested in so many
things and correspond it with so many
people about everything that his papers
offer a unique window into the
intellectual life of 18th century New
England as a historian I wanted to look
through that window and it was well
worth the 10 years I gazed through it
but I have to say that few readers felt
the same way the resulting biography is
number one and the worst-selling list of
books I've written so I think readers
often read biographies for different
reasons than historians write them but
not entirely different
I think the readers reason is the
opportunity to know even at long
distance someone unavailable in any
other way human beings are infinitely
variable and to know someone who lived a
life quite different from your own can
open up your life
maybe to enable you to live by curiously
in another time and place
that you couldn't otherwise touch you
couldn't otherwise have anything to do
with the same urge motivates historians
to and indeed it was my principal motive
in spending six or seven years maybe I'm
always under estimating the time was
probably more like eight or ten with
Benjamin Franklin I was arrogant enough
to think that I already already know
enough about eighteenth century America
in general but I needed to know after
all I'd spent those ten years with Ezra
Stiles who was a contemporary Franklin's
but I chose to spend so much time with
Franklin was like the beginning of so
many enterprises quite accidental but it
had to do with the personal magnetism of
the man had long been interested in and
excited by the projects underway in this
country to publish the complete papers
of all the founding fathers the most
important Enterprise I think historical
in the price of the last century these
projects which began over fifty years
ago have collected and will publish
everything that survives from the Pens
of these men and virtually everything
written to them the staffs of the
president different projects have
already done for all the founding
fathers the work that it would take a
single person a lifetime to do for any
one of them the Benjamin Franklin
project was and is located at the Yale
University Library over 36 volumes are
now in print but all the rest of
Franklin's papers that anyone would want
to locate or could locate in archives
all over the world had already been
photocopied
arranged chronologically at the project
well most of them 50 years ago and they
keep trickling in but most of them have
been there since the paper started so as
I happen to be at Yale University I
became very familiar with the Franklin
papers project and eventually had to be
the chair of the Administrative Board of
it but then came David Packard the
director of the Packard humanities
Institute and a computer expert
since the texts of all the papers
published and unpublished manuscript or
photocopy were available and organized
by date at each of the projects he
proposed to put them all on cd-rom discs
and it began with the Franklin papers he
presented me with a disc in which the
Franklin papers ultimately to occupy
probably around 47 volumes in print were
available to me on a single six-inch
disc he suggested that I write a brief
introduction to assist non-specialists
in discovering Franklin in this
bewildering array of materials he hopes
to make the disc widely available at
nominal cost
so I began like all historians at the
beginning and soon I was hooked
this was a man I wanted to know what
began as a brief character sketch
quickly got out of hand and as I
progress through his papers I felt
compelled to make the man what he
thought and did is accessible and
exciting to other people as he became to
me getting to know someone from another
age has to be quite a different
experience from
knowing anyone of whom you can ask
questions whether you get an answer or
not you can't read the person's body
language nor assess the meaning of a
facial expression a tone of voice a
pregnant silence but you can know as the
records of remains of a completed life
you don't have to guess what this person
will do would do in a given situation
how he or she will react to the
challenges that life presents you know
so far as the record will tell you what
he or she did do how they did meet
challenges you know things that your
subject did not know and couldn't have
known before deciding to do them you
know what side he or she took and as a
dispute with other people disputes of
neither side anticipated ten years or
two years or even two days before they
began and Benjamin Franklin is no
exception the records he left behind are
voluminous looking at him at any point
in his life we know that he is going to
do things that he had not yet imagined
doing and we also know things he had
already done but may have forgotten
things that we might suppose to be in
his consciousness when they have
actually disappeared from it the same
time we cannot know things that have
been lost from the documentary record
and also things that he took pains to
keep off the record take for example his
relations with his eldest and only
surviving son William Franklin what
don't we know we don't know who
William's mother was how Franklin met
her what sort of relationship they had
when William was born what happened to
his mother afterward most of what we do
know about Franklin's early life before
he became so important that people
started keeping anything he wrote most
of what we know that early life comes
from his autobiography written many
years after the events it describes
neither in the autobiography nor
anywhere else
does he offer a clue to William's mother
not even her name when you grew up in
the family that Franklin started with
Deborah Reid in 1730 did William himself
know who his mother was
I doubt it probably not and we most
likely will never find out not perhaps
that it matters but we'd like to know
but we won't on the other hand we know a
lot about William enough to know that
Franklin was very fond of him as a boy
and as the man the boy became when you
accompanied Franklin to England when he
went there in sevens in 1757 as agent
for the Pennsylvania Assembly and stayed
there with him until 1762 when Franklin
pulled strings with high-ranking people
he'd gotten to know and had his son
appointed royal governor of New Jersey
Frank father and son were very close
they lived together traveled together
worked on the agency's business and
London together they both returned to
America in 1762 William was a new bride
the new governor the New Jersey's
governor mansion was near enough so that
the two franklin families visited each
other regularly in the next couple of
years when franklin returned to england
in 1764 for a stay that lasted ten years
he kept William and four
about his efforts to get the British to
recognize American interests and rights
their loan letters and they remained
cordial and confidential even though
Franklin knew that his son was becoming
something of a royalist perhaps Franklin
to begin with was a royalist himself it
was for William that he began the
autobiography in 1771 with the words
dear son
he started the autobiography as a letter
to William after Franklin gave up on the
British and sailed for home in March and
yes March 1775 you cut there in May he
immediately began a detailed letter to
his son describing the foolish attempts
of the British to negotiate a
last-minute settlement with him on terms
that he knew Americans would never
accept even when he landed in
Philadelphia in May 1775 it was late in
that month or early June before father
and son could meet for a long evenings
conversation we don't know much about
that meeting but after it was over so
far as the record stand so far as we
will ever know Franklin never again
spoke a kind word to his son and
scarcely mentioned his name again until
he wrote his will in 1789 there he
explained that he left William nothing
virtually because and this is what he
says in the will because of the part he
acted against me in the late war but was
Franklin's way of saying it when you
became a loyalist Franklin took things
very personally including the American
Revolution when the war was over
Franklin resumed friendships with many
Englishmen who had supported English
policy including William strong
once his closest friend which throne of
Saturn Parliament and voted for measures
that brought on the revolution but
William was so much loved and trusted
could not be forgiven his political sins
while others were is the fact that must
have loomed large some more in
Franklin's consciousness but as with
Williams birth was not something you'd
occurred to discuss in any of his
surviving papers why not we will never
know in his lifetime
Franklin seemed an easy person to know
open and friendly he charmed nearly
everyone who met him the French in Paris
of course idolized him he could talk
with anyone and never put people off
with fancy airs he could chat with kings
and with beggars with equal ease but he
was not really as easy to know as he
seemed in one of his Poor Richard's
Almanack
he had written let all men know thee but
no man no thee thoroughly for the time
he reached fifty he was probably the
best known scientist in the in the world
because of his experiments in
electricity which laid the foundations
of theoretical foundations of the
science but no one doing thoroughly
everyone expected him to continue his
path-breaking work in electricity people
in England France Italy Germany begged
him to go on with his electrical
experiments Edie abandoned them in order
to serve the public and causes that he
did not always approve Franklin had
unlimited confidence in the future of
America and of Americans he had wanted
the colonies to remain in the British
Empire because of the American
countenance immense resources and he
thought of the continent is his
continent and the exponential growth of
its population along with its resources
he expected result in its being the
center of gravity in the Empire a center
of gravity would gradually shift from
Britain to America when the British
Ministry chose to alienate this most
valuable possession
Franklin's view of America's future
greatness was totally unshaken to his
English friends he repeated his
assurance of the future prosperity and
power of the new country but warned that
if Britain pursued in it's
unconscionable policies you will only
exclude yourselves from any share in it
with with these views fixed in mind he
apparently attempted to dissuade his
countrymen at the Continental Congress
from seeking foreign aid he was
convinced that the growing American
population widely dispersed in the
interior could never be conquered by a
British army we know all this from his
papers and we have voluminous records of
what was said and what was done in the
Continental Congress while he was
present but we only learned from a very
casual reference and a letter written a
couple of years later that he had tried
to persuade the Congress not to seek
help from France or any other country in
America's bid for independence I have
never yet changed the pen opinion he
wrote I have never yet changed the
opinion I gave in Congress but a virgin
state should preserve the virgin
character and not go about suturing for
alliances could wait with decent dignity
for the applications of others I was
overruled perhaps for the best when
Franklin who wrote that was already
engaged in suturing for the alliance
with France apparently is plea for the
United States to go it alone did not get
recorded in the journals of the
Continental Congress or in any surviving
letters of any of the members the
members chose him to do the very thing
he disapproved of he did what they asked
and did it more successfully than any of
their Americans could possibly have done
it was the only American with a
worldwide reputation and a reputation
that made people hold him in almost
nowhere else in his papers or anyone
elses
is there a hint that the task he
performed so brilliantly for ten years
was something he regarded as distasteful
and even inimical to American interests
this is obviously not a simple person
the doubtless were other things that
mattered to him that he did not talk
about silences they stand in the way of
knowing him thoroughly nevertheless
enough did get into those 46 47 volumes
to reveal a man worth knowing as
familiarly as he will let us consider
what we can learn from his wonderful
sense of humor so evident throughout his
papers when you like to want to know a
person is always useful if he has a
sense of humor the other founding
fathers only John Adams
I think had any real sense of humor at
all and it was hardly pervasive with
atoms and never exercised when he was
dealing was Franklin him I said with
Franklin
Equipe or a practical joke could be his
favorite mode of argument and a potent
political weapon he loved a Hornswoggle
political opponents with hoaxes like the
supported Edict of the King of Prussia
living in taxes in England because
England had admittedly been settled by
Germans the King of Prussia now declared
that it was high time England's
inhabitants helped pay the expenses
incurred by their mother country the
reader who started by taking this
seriously could scarcely go far without
recognizing it as a reductio ad absurdum
of england's pretended right to tax the
American colonies another
tongue-in-cheek essay rehearse the
standard arguments against freeing
slaves but applied them to Christians
held in bondage in foreign lands they
were all lazy
you couldn't intermarry with them you
couldn't trust them they would only work
if you've made them you know if they
were going to be there and all they had
to be slaves every pro-slavery argument
of the south is rehearsed and reversed
toward Christians Franklin sharpened his
sense of humor on public policies that
seemed to him self-serving vicious or
just plain wrong he also enjoyed making
fun of universal human folly but he did
not ridicule people who simply disagreed
with him Franklin just like people he
could not stand to be without company
for very long wherever he went he joined
dinner clubs very enjoyed to give and
take
friendly disputation but it would have
gone against his grain to belittle
contrary opinions to make fun of someone
he know was to make an enemy and
Franklin only made fun of people on
purpose and that was very seldom he
reserved his ridicule for people who are
already enemies enemies not of himself
but of his country or of all mankind
among them he conclude he included most
of the British ministry during the time
he was in England in his curbing his
sense of humor we got a clue the
comparable limitation be placed on the
significance he attached to his own
opinions his willingness to subordinate
his own opinion about foreign alliances
to the opinion of the Continental
Congress
public opinion he believed trumped all
private opinion his own included not so
much the rightness or wrongness of the
opinion in itself was what mattered but
simply its existence Britain could
govern America as Franklin told him
Parliament in 1766 Britain could govern
America with the expense only of a
little pen and ink because Americans
held the opinion that Britain would
govern them justly and wisely granting
them the same rights and privileges as
Englishmen at home in Britain taxed them
without their consent and ignored their
protests American opinion of British
justice changed
Franklin tried to explain to the British
that even if they were legally and
constitutionally right but she did not
admit the fact that Americans obviously
had the opposite opinion would make
British government of them ultimately
untenable public opinion could be
changed
but the British had heedlessly ignored
American public opinion and antagonize
dit persisting with policies that
inflame the antagonism when Franklin
became convinced that the British would
neither change their own opinion or give
way to American opinion he knew that
independence was inevitable and from
that point on he never tried to make any
accommodations in the months before
months before he gave up and went home
in 1775 Franklin did all he could to
shore up 11th hour negotiations in which
the British might conceivably change
their minds he even offered to
personally reimburse the East India
Company for the tea at lost in the
Boston Tea Party provided however that
the British reimbursed Boston merchants
for their losses incurred by the Boston
port act closing the Boston port but his
assessment of American opinion was that
his countrymen would never again consent
the authority of a British Parliament in
which they were not represented his
private opinion could conceivably have
favored more negotiating the opinion of
his constituents on the other hand was
not devotional it was a fact as he saw
that all the might of the British Army
and Navy could not change Franklin loved
the British Empire but he was an
American he happened to agree with
Americans view of their rights but the
important thing bull-riding
any personal preference was their
collective opinion just as their opinion
that they needed the French alliance
would override his opinion that they did
not I think the key to understanding
Franklin's public life lies in his
deference to public / private
in much of what he wrote was directed
toward influencing public opinion
precisely because public opinion was
what mattered but he never confused
public with private opinion in seldom
and confused private opinion with fact
public opinion right or wrong was fact
it was something there that had to be
dealt with and as such it ultimately
determined the character and actions
indeed the very existence of a whole
people the government state they
determined determined the coming into
existence of the United States in 1776
rather than in say 1775 by which time
Franklin thought it was time to be
independent Franklin has spent his life
dealing with public opinion and he'd
learned a great deal about the way it
operated and how it is driven in the end
for better or for worse by human nature
the most remarkable expression of what
he learned which I think will convince
you but he is indeed a man worth knowing
is in a letter he wrote to Lord High
Admiral Lord Howe in 1776 with the
Revolutionary War
already underway a war that Franklin
regarded as an aggressive war of
atrocities by the British Admiral Howe
was one of the men who had tried to
negotiate with Franklin in his last
weeks in England Franklin had made it
clear then that americanman opinion
would never again accept the authority
of parliament Admiral Howe and his
brother General Howe had now in July
1776 arrived off the coast of New York
off Staten Island the fleet and an army
to put down the rebels
gage had been unable to subdue at
Concord or Bunker Hill
before beginning operations Admiral Howe
had a mrs. Messinger carried a Franklin
a proposal to pardon those who would
submit to the authority of Parliament
after attacking Americans with fire and
sword he had already burned Falmouth the
British were offering to pardon the
people they were injuring pointing out
the absurdity of this proposal
Franklin added a little lesson in human
nature in the course of public opinion
sure to follow among house countrymen
the atrocious actions of the British she
said that has extinguished every spark
of affection among Americans but were it
possible he continued were it possible
for us to forget and forgive those
actions it is not possible for you I
mean the British nation to forgive the
people you have so heavily injured you
can never confide again and those as
fellow subjects and permit them to enjoy
equal freedom to whom you have given
such Just Cause of lasting enmity and
this must impel you were we again under
your government to endeavor the breaking
our spirit by the severus tyranny and
obstructing by every means in your power
our growing strength and prosperity in
other words the victims of oppression
may be able to forget and forgive it's
possible but they can never be forgiven
it's a brilliant observation by man from
whom we can still still learn much about
human nature even if even if he will not
let us know him thoroughly he has left
us enough to recognize a friend
of us all
I'll be glad to take any questions as a
lifetime Philadelphian I hold a very
high impression of Franklin and I was
somewhat surprised by what I took to be
the portrayal of Franklin in the popular
book on Adams by McCulloch I think
Franklin was pictured there as vain not
really hard-working seeking to and often
getting credit for what others did did
you have the same impression from the
book and how is the book wrong if it is
thank you that characterization
has written and spoken by John Adams
John Adams was paranoid about Franklin
totally paranoid he arrived in Paris in
1777 after Franklin had persuaded the
French to sign an alliance with them and
that was Frank Edwards what Adams had
come for a moment other things to help
Frank and get this alliance but Frank
had already done it and that was a bit
off-putting Adams I think and when he
arrived would this work already done he
writes in his journal I soon saw that if
any of the work of this embassy was to
be done I would have to do it the life
of dr. Franklin is a scene of continual
dissipation
he was on and on by a lazy Franklin is
etc etc Franklin is is there in Paris
but everyone in France worshipping him
he's able to get practically anything he
asks from the French government and what
Adams Adams then sits down and writes
letters to very gentle him how the
French should run their war it's it's
really common and you can't help but
like John Allen Adams he's so
transparent speaking of that at vanity
at John Adams is clearly the vainest
public figure in American history it
never stopped but the best
characterization of Adams quite
different from Adams his
characterization of Franklin his
Franklin's own characterization was
right I think to Robert Morris saying
that Franklin was always an honest man
sometimes a wise man but sometimes and
then some things totally out of his
senses and I think that describes Adams
very well but what he's was out of his
senses about mainly was dr. Franklin's
question but you know it
can we learn about his character through
the eyes of his wife through their
letters and can he say something about
their relationship since he spent so
much time overseas and away from her
right his relationship with Deborah may
seem a puzzle because his letters to her
and hers to him are all quite
affectionate and and they wrote
regularly all the time he was away but
he was away for ten years once and then
he was away earlier than that for what
1757 to 6205
no it was away from her 15 years while
she was alive that's a long time for
affection today demonstrated just by
mail and yet there are the letters
they're all quite affectionate and
talking about household things and so on
so what was his relationship to Deborah
well for a long time they lived together
in Pennsylvania before 1757 so certainly
had a long time together before they
started having a long time apart but at
the same time
Franklin enjoyed the company of women
young and old and that's very evident in
all this correspondence to whether in
some case in some cases the letters are
fairly flirtatious two young women were
not married Katie Greene in in Rhode
Island was
and the letters to her are the most
voracious I think but as soon as she
marries they stop being four pages yes
know anything about these other letters
and the flirtations that you talk about
I'm sure she did indeed in letters to
Katy Green she is sending regards and so
forth
no I'm pretty sure that Deborah knew
about all of them he wrote her from
England about the the family he was
living in the Stevens's and about the
Shipley's and Shipley's five daughters
they're one of the most charming letters
he ever wrote was to mrs. Shipley was a
lady who but her ladies named the
English parlance but but it's a it's
describing his taking the youngest
shipley daughter back to school Franklin
had been there for a couple of weeks
visiting the Shipley just when he rolled
it up and the first part of the
autobiography and he writes back tell me
how are they of their conversation and
the coach on the way back to the rural
school in which they marry off all of
her older daughters all older sisters
and it's a perfectly charming letter
about who who should be married to a
merchant who should be married to a lord
and so on
and it's clear that Franklin Franklin
liked children as well of all sexes
really so it's hard to fathom the
affection for Deborah I think that
William strong the printer was a very
good friend of wrote Deborah urging her
to come and join her husband and Deborah
refused to cross if she didn't wanna
cross the ocean and Franklin writes her
back as saying that he's read her letter
too strong saying she won't come and he
commends her for writing that letter ron
was under the impression all his
eloquence would persuade her but
Franklin known and it would not and so
on he's I have the impression he's a
little too happy that she's not coming
but that's just a clue no more than that
yeah I must say that your book is very
well written both from a historical and
a biography by biographical perspective
I felt like I got a good sense of both
the history and Franklin as as a person
but obviously technology has changed
much over the time for example you
talked about the letters being traded
back and forth and how long it would
take to for people to get an
understanding of that things might
happen before you know in the you know
while the letters were being translated
back and forth could you tell us first
of all how much politics has changed
in your mind because of the change of
technology
and what sort of things from Franklin's
character might be translated into
today's political milieu that's the
first question
secondly secondly tell us about Franklin
seems to have a conscience about slaves
but yet he owns slaves himself could you
tell us a little bit more about there oh
I'll try to answer the first question I
don't I'm not even quite sure of its
meaning of how technology has changed
politics not much changes politics I
think there there's this difference that
parties were considered a bad thing in
the 18th century that has changed and
campaigning for public office was
considered bad form
for high office in any rate another day
it would have been a black mark against
George Washington if he'd campaign for
the presidency or for John Adams or for
Jefferson that that is a kind of change
has nothing to do with technology just
has to do with culture the second
question is more difficult to answer
because Franklin gives us so few clues
in his early life I'm pretty sure that
Franklin did not regard slavery before
he was about 50-60 anyhow as anything
uncommon it was standard we only know
know that he had two slaves when he went
to England in 1757 because Deborah
ask about them it's an a letter from
Deborah that we first hear about these
slaves and Franklin answers that one of
them is runaway and is living with a
woman he knows where she where he is who
is sending him to school
he doesn't say whether he thinks that's
a good thing or bad thing the other one
is still with him and he says we rub we
rub together somehow or other he
obviously hasn't thought about slavery
very much it's the standard thing in as
a form of labor in many places if it was
standard in England in 1715 it was I
well I'll say it was standard it was not
illegal in England in 1757 in 1772 comes
Somerset's case which frees all slaves
in English declares there is no such
thing as slavery in England it's my
guess that that's when Franklin freed
those two slaves he had it doesn't say
so I don't know some time are there
there at some point whether they're not
his ways and at some point he comes to
see that slavery is really an evil thing
and the only the only place where that
begins to appear is after he's returned
from France and is about to go to the
Constitutional Convention he does not
the best of my memory speak against
slavery at the Constitutional Convention
probably because he thought it would be
futile he was more interested in Union
than he was in in slavery but he joins
with the Quakers and takes the lead as I
understand it and petition
in Congress once they Congress once the
Constitution is in place
he joins in a petition and may have
drafted the petition against slavery for
the abolition of slavery and then the
last thing he ever wrote for publication
was the hoax that I mentioned earlier a
letter from someone with a Muslim name
Evans I forgotten the name but it's an
argument as to why Christian slaves
should not be freed and in the way of
turning the pro-slavery argument on its
head and what is interesting to me about
that in another way is the implication
of racial equality that was contained in
it something that he did not have
earlier I think but the idea that
Christians being slaves makes this as
much sense as Africans being slaves and
by Christians he means it was the most
part Englishman or English Americans but
there is precious little about slavery
in Franklin's writings I think that if
he had lived longer he would have been
taking quite an active part in
anti-slavery movement in the 1790s when
the Quakers were about the only ones who
were doing anything about
decline key bird wrote a book called
inventing Ireland what is your sense of
how much self invention or invention by
other people there has been in
Franklin's image over the years well
that's a question that a lot of people
have have written about and in slightly
more highfalutin terms that I can handle
but I suppose Franklin did project an
image of himself when he thought it was
useful wearing a Coonskin cap in Paris
has to say something about the man but
over the in over the years and his
reputation it's come from mainly from
Poor Richard's Almanack and the sayings
of poor Richard particularly the
collection of them into one volume of
those that stress industry and thrift
and the publisher entitled the volume
the weight of wealth and it's left an
impression of Franklin as someone who
was one of whose main interest was in
making money and how to do it and
there's scarcely anything that ever
interested Franklin unless he thought
industry and thrift were very good
things especially for a country he was
interested in Americans practicing
industry and thrift in order to acquire
capital to
promote various ventures as an
independent nation but that stereotype
of Franklin as the business man's and
hard as the band interested in making
money is a very persistent one and it's
it's curious partly I suppose people
would say that Franklin affected a
common man sort of the picture of
himself and that may be true but I think
it was a picture that came naturally to
him he did not think of himself is more
important than other people and that's
the main lesson of his willingness to
suppress his own views which were
contrary to what public opinion demanded
what he thought when he thought he knew
what public opinion was he was willing
to suppress his own views that's a kind
of selflessness it's hard to believe
almost but there it is I mean that
that's on the record so and the
autobiography is another place where
people who think Franklin is
constructing a persona they turned to
this and yes he started out as a letter
to his son but really as a kind of
guidebook to bringing up young people I
suppose
and he does it as a persona as a
description of his own use and success
I don't know I think that what you see
in Franklin is what you get you get what
you see in Franklin he won't give you
everything but what he gives you is is
straight it's not something that's
constructed deliberately as much as as
many English scholars seem to think
edmond morgan is a history professor at
yale university for more information on
Benjamin Franklin visit Yale University
Press online at yale.edu slash